there is inequality Orszag looking at
some of the new research out there says
not so fast maybe it's company to
company inequality this is a fascinating
idea that inequality is about Apple
versus a more mundane corporate
structure yeah so I think we have paid
far too little attention to firm level
behavior the you know what what drives
firms so we have seen something like
two-thirds of the rise in wage
inequality is because average peut firms
has diverged as opposed to within firm
you use the apple of McDonald's or
whether the answers anybody at Apple
makes a rocket than anybody in McDonald
exactly um returns on invested capital
of also diverge in the 1960s only 1% of
non-financial firms earned fifty percent
or higher return on invested capital in
the 2000s 14 / straight it's a huge
change Lou Alexander / Nomura had one of
my quotes of the year I'm Dickens three
years ago the basic idea is is the
computer my fan friend frenemy or enemy
at Apple my computer's my friend maybe
at McDonald's is my enemy how much of
the productivity technological progress
total factor productivity all the Orszag
mumbo-jumbo how much of that is just
about the computer being my friend or
enemy well it's clearly been a big
driver IT investments but one of the
puzzles that has emerged over the past
few years is that we continue to pour
money into information technology
increasingly in software as opposed to
hardware and yet it's not showing up in
the macro level aggregate productivity
numbers do you agree with fareed zakaria
the liberal arts education is valuable
today we're should everybody code uh
there's no reason you can can't do both
I think thank you okay that's the answer
is you gotta do both I mean the idea
here is if you get to Apple you don't
just get there by mean there's six
people to Apple that got there just
writing code yeah everybody else was
well rounded and doing better but I
would also say that one of the things
that we learn from Silicon Valley is
that there is a ceiling to what you can
do if you can only code is that the
people who truly make money the
visionaries are the ones who can corral
a bunch of coders and give them a job to
do and say how that job fits into the
economy and I think that's what brought
that learning
how to you know manage a sequel database